ah hello everyone welcome I hope you had
a great weekend Easter or not today
we're very excited we have a special
guest former WWE Superstar AJ Mendes
Brooks and now she's an author look at
this
you wrote a whole book crazy is my
superpower which by the way I guess now
I can't use that as my book title that's
you know what you got to it first well
done this book is extremely thick you
wrote all these words there's so many
words I tried to write a book one time
and it just ended up weeping so we'll
talk about this in a minute all about
that's a she she wants to play witcher 3
yes what you've beaten right I have just
my god alright alright and we talked a
little bit about this before hello
Jordan Davis I just said hi to you there
you go Jordan with a why really okay
your choice yeah but anyway we're
playing The Witcher 3 and I'm just gonna
say straight up guys I'm very
embarrassed because I know we did this
for clueless gamer conan and i played
witcher 3 and he had sex on a unicorn it
scarred me forever
boy lincoln when we did that when we did
that in the game company Projekt RED i
believe helped us out and i just got to
skip around in the game and frolic about
and i didn't have to earn anything and
now I had to start this game over this
weekend and I was very embarrassed to
tell AJ we're like 90 minutes in dude
it's it's awful this is gonna be nothing
to you but you know what this will be a
fun little and this is gonna be
nostalgic you know what I would love
that that's all I didn't read bad
Redemption that's like Cougars are
[ __ ] no it's fine
alright so let's get going uh what do
you want a player do you want me to do
you want me to stumble through this Oh
God alright let's see we'll take turns
first of all so here's where we are we
have to find some first of all how windy
is this it's very much so it's the rest
of the game this windy
there's different weather you get
different alright good cuz it's real
this is freaking me out I'm not a big
wind guy I don't like a lot of wind
people tell ya what's real way exactly
alright you know you stir you stir you
stir you just beat this game so we have
to so all right so let me just fill you
in because I'm obviously a Witcher
expert yeah we're trying to look for
something around this campsite
because we have to get the buckthorn so
but before that happens we're looking
for yeah we have to follow the tracks
here I think I know right maybe they
were walking back I say bath King a me
the clicker I call it a clicker cuz I'm
like two feet up no yeah I fell down
there last night you could totally fall
down there and die no you won't die you
fought your mother on you probably hurt
severely twist an ankle
all right so and so you wrote this book
crazies my super heart it's a story of
your life which is I have a couple
things I have a couple questions for you
first of all David Sedaris famously when
he writes about people he lets them read
it before it goes out a story like your
sister did you did you have a section in
there like talking about you know advice
if you have a sister things to do did
you let your sisters read this did you
god no no oh my god so one day so it
just came out on April 4th I believe
yeah and have have has her family read
it and what do they think so my sister
has read it she read it um when I got
the galleys in which is like early
version please listen to this author
over here when I got the proof so yeah
I'm just like staring at these red foot
prints right now I don't know what I'm
doing
I can also wander around it I just want
to answer I will answer them all right
and by the way I'm just I'm getting out
of here we're not doing this part I'm
just gonna go look at the muck arm
oh do I have to do this well yeah that
might help you find
alright alright so anyway you continue
people want it I'm here every week but
people want to hear from you so I'll
just wander around I did send her a
version and she was very moved and loved
oh great that's cool and then you know
had a dinner like months later when
there was a little bit of alcohol with
her she's like no no you know she's such
a hero
I think yes I think she came up OK oh
you know what that's what Conan says too
right after he hits me a bunch punches
me and then he's like I do this exactly
that's true you know what it's like the
opposite of love is indifference exactly
you know if you like you didn't mention
somebody in the book that's the people
you hate yes and I noticed I wasn't
mentioned in the book so what's your
beef with me yeah you're right I'm so
sorry oh all that killing I just I can't
stop these exactly I feel like you're
gonna be the one murdering me alright so
let's talk seriously though how hard is
it to write him look not just even about
yourself but just literally to type that
many words it's crazy so like when you
cuz you're writing about and I will say
also writing about your life this also
seems very difficult because it's kind
of like you can't really make stuff up I
mean you could lie about how you feel
which is what I do all the time but you
know I'm saying but it's like you know
it's like it's true like so did you
start there's so much like a person's
life is so vast like how did you decide
what to include and what not to like did
your editor help you like well we don't
need to tell people what you ate for
breakfast when you were 13 I want to
know
no I'm not it's like oatmeal is that
like a Witcher thing yeah yeah that's
like an oatmeal okay it's like a it's a
green where does it come from I don't
work for Farina I live in all right you
know what Frank let's pass help me you
know figure out what kind of pick the
best moment right we sort of just wanted
it to be like a like the most formative
moments of my life I see some bread up
there oh there we go all right these are
the goddamn foot prints we're not what
stuck here chat just relax we're gonna
get out of here in a second okay
everyone just chill out all right what
are you talking about all the Undertaker
will get to wrestling in a second all
right chill out and then we'll get to my
wrestling career which is what everybody
wants to hear the other side can you
jump can I jump there we go here we go
all right
so yeah so you you came up with probably
a large outline right you know less
about okay here's what happened in all
this behind-the-scenes moans wrestling
it was more about you know growing up in
poverty and and and and how I overcame
that to get to wrestling right so it was
kind of the best of both cuz that's the
thing too is like that's what I liked
about your book is it's it's for
wrestling fans but it's also it's has it
deals with a much larger scope that's
much more relatable I think to anybody
which is and a great not a trick but
that's really great I think that's what
makes that's what separates a book from
just like okay cool this is the time I
put some of the figure-four leglock
versus like hey we're all we all deal
with stuff like this whether you have
mental illness or not oh come on bro all
right I know I didn't even make it past
the part where they keep telling you
tutorials and you know what I need them
also unfortunately ooh well done that's
going on was there stuff that
you were even hesitant to talk about in
the book yeah I think I'll ever ask you
like serious questions just like yeah
there's a really dark time
oh wait Griffin's here we are yeah they
said this is about to be a dark time for
us my favorite thing in games is when
people when the characters talk to
themselves cuz no one talks to themself
like this you don't walk around you're
like huh I mean I do but I'm insane I'm
like at Albertson's I'm like that to get
free range but god I'm so hungry it's
just like one of those things oh oh yeah
was there stuff in there you are
hesitant to include like darkness is
where I live so let's go let's go I love
the dark a version that didn't have like
the darker stuff that I went through
like so my mom yeah and and the news
realized like sack up and say it I'm
gonna tell you like hey let's talk about
this right the stigma
then I had to be the first like yeah
totally I have an open book you have to
be an open book come on put it up that
was well that's okay it's no one's
watching cameras doesn't isn't connected
and yeah that's true and that's the
thing too is like I'll say you like you
know I've I've written stuff on the
internet that's been very personal to me
and it's before I hit like post I'm like
oh no the toothpaste is out of the - I
mean people know that about you and so
it's it's you know it's really
interesting that's it's a big decision
to do something like that
I'm I'm kind of a notoriously private
person I you know we're just talking
about me not understanding Instagram
okay right I'm not good at like sharing
like I can't share like day-to-day stuff
alright we're finished guys only two
levels in this game so I think
done it but I think wouldn't you have
liked so many people like paying
attention to you and some of the eyes on
you it's your responsibility to maybe
not you know
tweet like boobie selfies and maybe you
should you know talk about something
that matters
oh yeah and so that was sort of you know
to me I'm very private but I could be
very exposed and horrible if it counted
absolutely if it's gonna help others
yeah for sure and by the way you have a
Hall you have the whole thing in your
but you hate you notoriously hate
selfies and there's like only eight
girls Oh
AJ thinks there's only eight top eight
kind of scenarios where you get so K
yeah
so what the first one is what my if
you're in front of like a monument okay
now this bath town as a monument because
heard I've taken a lot of selfies with
back I mean a chat don't answer that
don't be gross why did I even bring that
up I'm just encouraging them the worst
sorry okay but sorry not at all right
national mine no you should be respected
like a national monuments right you
should be yes I got that for my I got a
onesie of that for my niece my sister
yeah did you get that whoops
see this is the kind of pro gaming I
need here yeah you know let's call her
Roche just like you're right or die yeah
it is so I'm gonna name my kid wrote
Roche blurt no maybe
no yeah no I just you know boy named
suit you're trying to toughen them up
all right here we go
wait what are the other so what are the
other selfie oh you have a dog I have a
dog what's your dog's name Larry Larry
Talbot Larry oh that's a great name
thank you
that's great hopefully more wolf than
man I would hope my dog is a human face
it's really scary Oh weird sex thing
like you're making sure to get a dog in
your house you're Rick James in your
Rick James in it are we okay no Jesus
this is like two years ago
all right here you it's really swag have
sweaty gross you know yeah I think it's
funny to like take a stance on one thing
and not like ride the middle line sure
always make choices always make sure
that makes drunk choice and I enjoy like
pissing people off and so for me I know
everyone you know love selfies so much
and so I thought it'd be really funny to
be incredibly judgmental and yeah it's
also at a section where I'm like telling
my wit beer bottle says beer bottle says
Roach's a female our horses a female oh
you've been play for hundreds of hours
you didn't even know you're never like
check I think I looked at a tail in that
mime and I don't know what that was how
did you not know if you could swim Fred
I just started playing I'm sorry it's
been a long no - Fred Chris Murphy happy
birthday there you go yes exactly yeah
it's oh it's all like it's a warning
slash advice to your daughter
that's it no I love it no wait what was
what was harder like becoming a WWE like
your WWE audition or writing the whole
book because the audition was like three
days right it was a crazy yes so I paid
to tryout down in Florida Records crazy
compound
we've had other wrestlers on here and
who have talked about this and it sounds
horrifying because I hate physical
exercise right and so do i I mean like
I was not talented whatsoever in any
sort of like I still if you throw a ball
at me I'll just disagree did you can
okay your I was good at wrestling oh
there I can lift some weights now um
let's hold woman what she's doing I
don't know but she's got a sassy little
she's standing there all sassy she needs
to oh it's the frickin pan mission
what's the pan mission it's so obscure
she's just like hey I've got a pan in
there can you grab it for me guys this
is what you want to see when you're
playing the witcher's pan retrieval
exciting action and retrieval read says
never knew Roach is a female just assume
devs didn't render horse pain it's
Monday it's Monday my week is just
starting and I have to read the words
course start not how am I gonna top it
is now worst pain is a phrase that's
gonna be the name of my book horse pain
not rendered exactly yes you go by AJ
Mendez Brooks right okay there we go
settled that settled that long-standing
exactly my horse doesn't identify as
male female that's right worth see
Phoenix we're living in a fluid general
society we have a non-binary identifying
horse you know I think that's what it is
pan retrieval that's right we're doing
it can you be nice to her sometimes he
girl knows how to handle pans I'm not
sure what that means
I don't know handle pans pit pan handler
Oh pan handling stupid shot on to the
sport squash love squash
I love the vegetable and the gay in the
sport wait so this is cool so now you're
you're like traveling around talking
about yourself weirdly yes it's very
strange that's very odd right yeah I
mean I've done so much media and
but you're basically sure you're a
character your character right and so
it's you know it's strange to step out
of the character and then just hope
people show up just for me like that's
sort of asking a lot what are you
talking about your eyes sorry your eye
it's great you've got a lot of great
stuff your name and you just by the way
didn't you shouldn't make the New York
Times bestseller less so now your New
York Times bestselling author dude
that's huge that's that's why people
come out to see you that's why very good
luck somebody asked what do you what do
you think about what's your favorite
Batman game oh the Arkham games city I
think yeah nothing last night was last
Arkham nevertheless yes and also that
last mission when you have to like chase
the cars and then hit him from behind
yeah oh my heart oh my stars and garters
Arkham Asylum is super fun I gotta say I
love what they did like how they changed
their their take on all the Batman
characters really fun like scarecrow
like how they went in a different way
than like the movies I thought was great
yeah and like I kind of made their own
thing which was the scariest thing on
earth like I'm crazy
stole my soul green and I also love
there was a thing I don't remember if in
the first was the first Batman Arkham
game Arkham Asylum might have been right
but so I remember playing that on 360
Xbox 360 and there's a moment in it
where it makes it like the game screwed
up do you remember this this is the
first time you meet scare Cove
oh you start walking and and all of a
sudden like you're your xbox like
restart so I was like no I didn't save
oh my god and then it starts over and
you realize it's all a dream like in its
fake and the Joker or the Scarecrow the
Joker is like the head of Arkham and
you're like a prisoner and I was like oh
that's great it cuz it made me actually
scared like for real that's like plain
metal yup Metal Gear Solid where you put
the did you ever play that game when you
have to move yes oh my god oh my god yes
yeah Psycho Mantis yes and there's a
great boss in Metal Gear Solid where you
ease like I've gotten you know whatever
telekinesis put your controller down it
vibrates and he moves it around it's
awesome I love that it's like 4d it's
like playing in yes and then if you yes
David Marcus grease which Batman and
Joker I never played Sons of Liberty
okay so there's this moment where the
game is like if you play from they call
you and they're like maybe you should
stop playing it's been five hours
there's like a moment where you look
really freaked out pretty bad and it's
really trippy oh my god that's awesome
and when you've been playing a video
game for like ten hours you're already
tripping so how did you decide to write
a book where did that come from
um I just always liked good bucket lists
like a bucket list that's cool that's
awesome my sister and I used to kind of
joke that I'm just doing right [ __ ]
who cares who cares what you gonna beat
you up like yeah just take yourself yeah
um so meet my sister Burke and of always
joke about um this is like anything bad
that happened was just like fodder for
the tell oh yeah and so it's kind of our
way of like dealing with bad situations
it's like okay one day if I can do that
and maybe you know that's Wow even
that's really scary yes very much
yeah and try a new courier I love it
though that's right yeah it's working
out great it's working out awesome
that's awesome and I love like I will
say like the fact that it was kind of a
promise to your sister that probably
means you would go through with it
because I know promises I make to other
people I follow but the promise to
itself I break all the time look we
don't need to go to bed right now I
promised myself I'd get some sleep
tonight drink a lot of coffee tomorrow
which I've obviously done this morning
because I am a psychic today exactly
Oh fall out of you playing Fallout New
Vegas is your favorite what are you
insane
me no no somebody said New Vegas is our
favorite you're crazy it's too buggy to
buggy guys too buggy follow form is
great we did Kurt and I did a clueless
gamer where we had to where I might have
told the story on here but this is a
disgusting story that I'll tell you
anyway we had we they made a suits like
they measured us and made us like
skin-tight volt suits like leather
yeah and Beth will put a link in the
chat room buddy and so you know his
Conan I are kind of this almost the same
kind of body type and so we did this
whole cold open where him and I he he
it's gonna be like a World War three and
he goes into the Gilmore Girls gazebo
like that's where this vault is cuz they
shoot Gilmore Girls in a lot so like we
did a whole thing yeah we will okay yeah
and so anyway so is really funny and so
he crawls down into the vault and then
I'm there and it's evolved and we play
the game we're both it's yeah it's great
it's but the gross part is so we shot
this whole thing and he was wearing his
skin tight suit underneath other clothes
and then we shot a whole clueless gamer
with it and at the end of the day he had
to go we had to do reshoots of him
crawling down and so I had to put on his
disgusting skin tight our interns about
to throw up
he's literally about to throw up okay I
did when I was like like wet like
soaking filth need a go ba suit and
crawl up and down a ladder and I've
never felt closer to another game I was
just covered in Kony's DNA it was so it
was so spicy oh we're so far beyond
dating you're like whatever the next
level above like marriage and like blood
is so yes yes yeah see there yeah oh
please I bequeath it to you Erin Blair
talking about your wrestling career my
wrestling career
have one I've done a lot of joke
sketches where I've wrestled I
accidentally got punched in the face one
time which hurts by the way how many
times have you gotten punched in the
face would you guess oh my god I've
probably gotten punched in the face
that's so many times I love that you
have a favorite punch in the face too
many Oh God my favorite of all of these
stories would be a woman tried out who
no joke held the title that year for
world's strongest woman and punched me
in the face by accident oh Jesus
and like I was just everywhere and she'd
get signed even though like she was so
amazing she should have yeah but um yeah
so I got to like save the rest of my
life I got punched in the face for the
world stops Wow and I was gonna say you
guys can't see it on camera but the way
the reason AJ has her hair like this
because this side of her face is totally
concave there's a there's a there's like
an imprint of a fist just right here
it's really weird I don't know it's the
cameras you can't see normally that's
crazy
good god man yeah that's one at least I
only Conan just goes when he beats me
it's just below the neck so it's a lot
of although he did kick me we did a
thing with the Nerdist guys at Nerdist
bowling thing where he kicked me really
hard in the kidneys with like pointed
dress shoes and that was that actually
really hurt oh that was fun that was fun
right those guys are good
Hardwick is hard look at those guys are
really funny I was just trying to go
look at your quests and it was sending
me to a tutorial yeah because I have it
[Laughter]
all right man this game literally takes
oh here we go
it's so it's so deep guys Oh something
else have you played Mass Effect I know
I have not played Andromeda is like the
new one have you played the old ones a
little bit now do I need to play the I
know the new ones kind of starting a new
story but everyone says two and three
are like some of the best video games of
all time I've definitely heard that
and I agree I heard some people were
disappointed with the way the last one
ended you want me to take over
okay yeah somebody some people are
disappointed how they way three ended
right okay but I don't know like to me I
like I like a game that has like an open
world but I do definitely lean toward
like games like The Witcher where like
just take me to the ending like even if
there are few different options like
when there's too many options I sort of
lose my mind
oops I'm just gonna no God I will say
one of my favorite things in Skyrim is
just murdering guards Oh
Skyrim Mike okay so this is how much of
a twelve-year-old I am my favorite thing
in the sky Rose was just like getting
houses and they did have a dlc you dlc
what you just have a family and stuff
yeah that's like I would just walk
around and decorate my house Oh focused
he says yeah the old ones are way better
there's so much better than drama miss
master car the old ones better a Raging
Bull where's your boss Conan I don't
know man probably sharpening his knives
to come in and savvy maybe I don't know
his access should I come out with a
Witcher multiplayer know how I feel
maybe not I don't know I just I to me
like and this is definitely not like
this day and age everyone is all about
the multiplayer yes yes so much food
sitting in food Cheetos I can't I can't
I can't do yeah it's too much stress man
I suck at video games I don't need to be
reminded how I escaped from my life
company yeah I don't need to also know
that I suck in a video game
I don't I'm saying it's just too much
I'm not I'm not good at it I don't like
it I don't like talking to people
playing it again just let me soak into a
nice red dead redemption we're like I
remember oh my god when I got when I
first moved out to LA I got robbed like
right after I moved out here my whole
house got broken into and the one thing
yeah exactly the thing I was like one of
things I was most upset about
I think this is old now you're about to
learn something about me was the fact
when they stole my xbox they also stole
the hard drive you know like and so like
my fallout game was
gone like hundreds of hours of wandering
around the wasteland nights just come
home and just like one or the wasteland
and I was I was like you [ __ ] aren't
gamers obviously like drop my house fine
take everything I don't care take a dump
on my floor but leave the hard drive
dude come on
Oh monsters you monsters have I played
The Last of Us yes Ashley wept during
the Last of Us if you didn't dedenne's
yeah you're a mutt you steal hard drives
you're a monster
oh my god are you excite you have to be
excited about the new one last of us - I
have mixed I'm excited because I will
play it but um I have mixed emotions
because I felt like that was like the
perfect ending and I agree I agree I
agree
don't come back to it just keep us in
that world maybe but don't I don't want
to see Ellie and Joel again and they're
gonna be there so I know it was funny we
had Ashley Johnson on who is obviously
played ally in the game and she was so
cool to talk to her but also weird cuz I
just finished the last yeah that's good
ah it's like knowing have you ever been
phone friends with somebody where you
only talk on the phone and then you
finally meet in real life oh oh very
smart because when I was an intern here
when I was first an intern one of our my
boss's wives would call all the time so
I talked to her for like a year before I
met her and it was so weird cuz I was
like oh you're a stranger but then
you're saying oh no I um was obsessed
with anime growing up and I actually
named my wrestling character oh right
daily after Wendy Lee Cowboy Bebop yes
yes uh and and I almost I was going to
talk to her on the phone for this like
project I was doing mm-hmm and I like
mister like if this was a time when I
didn't have a phone like my mom had the
cell phone okay okay and so I missed her
call sorry man she left a voicemail and
I could never call her back because I
was so intimidated by the voicemail
really because it was hey and my voice
my mom is voice mail I love it so I
never got to put her in my book oh my
god that's hilarious
I know it's it's so funny like well
here's actually a question like you
you have performed for millions of
people so like do you get nervous like
are you nervous about meeting people who
are gonna read your book and I mean it's
such a different dynamic yeah oh Christ
what do I have to do well let's get past
this alright what's like the formula I
can make a cat finally I can make my own
cat
Oh mr. snuggle buttons you're gonna come
back to life that's right I never had a
cat named mr. snuggle one but I'd have a
cat named Footloose and Rufus and oh my
god Otis all died so there you got three
cats it died all orange by the way my
first cat Footloose I don't mean to talk
about my cats guys I know we had AJ
because he has six toes on each foot
cats have that guys back me up chat
diamond doctors best aspect of cowboy
bebop is yoko kanno soundtrack make a
cat's his finest I can't I don't have
the ingredients bro
all right you're hot the girl with the
laptop see always happens guys that'll
back the creepiness or dial it up on me
how am I not pretty
look at this silvery main you bastards
no one cares about me
all right uh anyway sorry we're we're
talking about making cats let's do this
dump ocean we have to okay it says
you're on wait honey my honey I need to
go to Thunderbolt how does this happen
give me out of here okay the way I
selected here we go here we go here we
go guys were gonna do it it's gonna be
amazing it's good to be the best potion
we've ever seen no you know what wait
where's our thing it disappeared maybe I
made it let's go to our inventory let's
go to our potions okay I must equip it
got it gonna equip the [ __ ]
out of this potion on equipping this so
hard you guys you can make anything
gross with inflection alright alright
there we go
or is it a quit is this you know yeah
now you just I just unequipped it
perfect alright just want to make sure I
could on equip stuff to you guys I'm
afraid of commitment
alright here we go fun fact about Yoko
Kanno
soundtrack today I like illegally
downloaded it how you're on camera why
are you saying it was like 14 and I put
it on a CD and this is back when they
were Walkmans children of the future
daughter so I had like old school like
headphones and like this big CD player
and like I would listen to like I love
it that is some nerdy [ __ ] and I love it
here's on nerdy I am i this is back
could see the CD age I was so into Star
Wars I had I went to Sam Goody and had
them specially order me a jet like a
Skywalker Orchestra rendition of like
universe and it took like six weeks yeah
yeah if that happens you get your
virginity back I think
yeah just like here you go yeah sorry
get off the goddamn horse
alright here we go alright captain she's
already married dude yeah that's what
the ring is about that's not yours we're
drinks I mean look I'm married to the
game you know so I don't you know I
don't marry not the rapper just like the
you know the so I don't wear ring I
don't need to here we go
Beth one little bet take Aaron's job
during this stream by the way that's
right where the stream is done
burski loves the Sam Goody shadow oh my
god by the way there's a great Tower
Records documentary by Colin hey that's
amazing
that's really good you got kids you
don't know how hard it was back in the
day you guys you made did you make
somebody a playlist like you burn them
off Leila sure make um a playlist on
because that or something oh good mix it
until I was like 20 so all right well
have you done it since have you done it
for your husband no I don't like them
yeah I'm just saying all right well you
know what what what my point is back in
the day you had to decide on two numbers
there's only a certain number I would
make myself yeah okay there we go
I'll be be vodka baby but your favorite
color and then just listen to it while
weeping on the bus but but you know you
had to decide like what's now you can
make a Spotify playlist like a million
songs yes there's no art to it yeah they
don't know about how if you wanted to
like really get everything out of video
game you get like when those guys it was
like heavy ass book yeah absolutely
which is like way more money than I
could like a forward base exactly I used
to go to the library and photocopy I
also used to go to library this is
really sad and now we're just going down
as I told you I like darkness I used to
go and listen to the shadow remember the
shadow it was like an old radio play
they had cassettes of that library I
would go and and just copy like you know
whatever take them so I could get a lot
of them at once cuz you only take out
like one or two guys I've led a very sad
life that's right exactly
oh here we go let's talk more about AJ
area I heard you like rock band rock
music for your favorite rock band
oh nice nails let's get a close-up of
those nails get into camera those yes
look at those nails
there's pizza on the thumb and I'm like
I'm so and then everything you mean
you're not good you're doing it is that
you're holding your hand this pizza and
Space Invaders and coffee and donuts and
puppy paw print everything you need in
life holy wait I think okay so murder
right yeah wait do you want it here you
do this yep give it to the warrior Oh
John Devore's in the chat sometimes I
come on to twitch to share my thoughts
and feelings Danny Devore he used to
work here
oh hello John Devore you've any
questions for AJ Joe horse probably
writing a book write about his life is
growing up as a woman yes see you a lot
in common
whoo I know there's a way to be better
at this than I am
yes I don't have the bow I'm horribly
horribly I don't do I
I don't know are we supposed to be using
your I can look at it with my eyes I
don't need I can use what my my or
killers I'm regular signature mr.
Naumann Dominic's wants energy of like
Dark Souls I have nately Dark Souls well
you're it's pretty amazing what's your
opinion on games that are super hard and
frustrating like that's like cuz Dark
Souls kind of made its reputation I'm
like [ __ ] you gaming right because like
there are some people who are like it's
all about the challenge and I love that
but I'm all about the story like that's
why I look there we go so much yes I
just want to like enjoy the story what
the writers like have
yeah oh right in the ass get him in the
ass nice you go out in the ass Griffin
vitamin exactly every time no I agree
because games are a lot like movies
these days yeah only I like to say like
they're kind of more intense because
it's a more proactive form of
entertainment because you are the person
yeah so when they die you a piece of
human side it really yeah I will sink
like 120 hours into a chore time Final
Fantasy 10 is when my favorite games
all-time I loved fought for all of the
Witcher yes I haven't played the newest
Tomb Raider like my version of her I
mean the first one was really really
yeah yeah I played that - yeah we did
that for close camera - and I there's
yeah I killed Conan quite a bit sir sir
- want some AG any chance your book will
come out in Italian or do you suggest to
buy it in English now oh my gosh I think
we have not done foreign rights yet look
at us
plug if you yeah but we'll see I hope I
hope it'll get out there more now you
know yeah bestseller exactly it's gonna
be in everything
wait are you gonna do other plans to do
an audio oh I buy the place you a your
book and are you gonna read it I already
recorded yeah awesome
I love that wait okay wait so tell her
tell us about what no why like what's
that what's the thing so you finally are
gonna do an audio book by the way of a
book on your own life it's called crazy
is my superpower it's out now go buy it
we're gonna get to by the way there's
family photos in here we're gonna get
you into soap oh yes yes okay so you're
gonna do audiobook right so then what's
that what happened so I such an anime
fan and like a voice actor fan like that
like I in my head and I do like a
scooby-doo movie like the voice a voice
and what do you know that oh it's great
I like like flirted with Scooby I think
is really creepy or Mindlin yeah I wish
Hey and so I was like really jazzed and
I thought like oh yeah this is awesome
and like sort of forgot like I had to
read the book that I wrote oh wait I
gotta read this piece so you like I like
I love Twitter because it's just like my
dumb jokes I'm like I really just popped
myself and like like I enjoy my own
stupidity you do it for you I really do
do it for you and so like all the jokes
my [ __ ] I thought you know like they
made me laugh and they're asinine and
and then you have to read those out loud
in front of a director and someone who's
editing it the words out loud for the
first time oh god oh my gosh
why did I write top hat full of dicks
wait why did you write Tom pet dicks
what's the context of that this is a
real-life conversation with my editor I
bet there's just like one line about
like how if you work in like this is the
service industry like the cashier or
Bristo huh um your day will
unequivocally suck a top hat full of
dicks okay
is this when you worked in the spa this
is when I worked at Pathmark supermarket
okay and I hope we can Kirsten here yeah
I've been swearing so I wrote the first
I wrote bowl full of dicks
and my editor was like um you can maybe
add a word you can do that can we find
something classier that's very funny
I love that I love that I love that fine
nothing I don't and you can't go monocle
full of dicks yeah unless I looked I
looked at a top hat full of dicks threw
my monocle the only way that's pretty
classy - exactly right exactly
that is so who am i Michael Caine
looking at a topical index through my
monocle
my monocle made of dicks my scrotum
monocle what am I talking about my god
exactly no wait so you and you had
obviously a bunch of your very self-made
person you you've had a bunch of crazy
odd jobs before getting E so for the
people out there this is cheesy but now
this is who you are you have to do it
you've written a book it's part of you
about your life like what would you save
those people who like somebody who's
working in a supermarket but wants to
get like their dream like you know don't
do it no you don't do it kid all right
well like you know like like looking
back in your experience like like now
that you have the the you're fortunate
enough to have hindsight in hindsight's
20/20 what are some of like the moments
you could look back in your life and be
like oh that's where I really went for
or that was important um I mean I think
the whole point of writing the book was
just some people know that like I came
from absolute rock bottom and if it's
possible for me to get you know onto
international television to be a
wrestling champion when I write you know
90 pounds soaking wet sick little girl
in New Jersey living in a car yeah like
I could get there weird that you took
baths in your clothes - no that's true
like you can do it what is anyone else's
excuse exactly that's great exactly so
oh oh this is one of those quick
decision makers oh you took the coin is
that bad I don't know okay there might
be like a greedy element I know later on
the game if you take money in front of
Siri she shames the [ __ ] out of you
really yeah she just looks like a young
Philip Seymour Hoffman exactly Oh Fred
wants to know what's your favorite game
of all time it's probably some sort of
toss-up between who's getting murdered
it's some sort of toss up between Metal
Gear Solid the first one for PlayStation
and
that could be into it by the way I don't
know if that screams of pleasure could
be like a little Fifty Shades and come
exactly do it
choosing the couch awesome totally fine
trade trademart Chuck's by the way
you've got married in Chuck's you got
married glitter Chuck sparkly glitter
Chuck's this thing is annoying me can we
just do the ability point thing oh yes
there you got it all right here
yeah that's great I mean like and and
here's some like and now that you're out
of your now that you're an author
best-selling author and out of the WWE
looking back like what are some of the
parts that you're gonna miss the most
it's a we would call ourselves
professional waiters because we would
you know fly for four hours you get to
the building 10 p.m. yes yes you have 12
minutes or like if you were a girl you
had two and a half minutes and then and
then you just drive 300 miles to the
next night oh yeah you know you really
wait you know time when you're in front
of the crowd yes yes that's true
sometimes I start like scream in a
supermarket exactly take a bath and then
yeah yeah yeah have you played the
phantom pain people want to know have
you played yeah yeah yeah which is the
last one I think last minute users
because of all of the drama yes yeah it
was really trippy like I mean I'll do an
Anglophile video could you met anywhere
yeah but um it was a little trippy for
me death stranding looks insane by the
way there's new yes it looks crazy
awesome oh now of course now the chats
still talking about dicks and top hats
look guys you know this one miss Savior
sent a dick pic at least clasp it up I
know like all the dick pics I get all
the time exactly yeah exactly if it you
know like draw me one of your draw me is
one of your pictures jack
little put a little thought into it guys
you know a blurry dick nobody wants to
see that I love it what are the parts
eat and so I would I would imagine like
that's probably a part you also don't
miss is all the waiting's going from
place to place
I think the travel like see you know it
really was 300 days a year
unless you you know broke something off
of your body and you can't physically do
it right um and so it's just bad you
don't want to break things off it really
was but there was definitely you know
sometimes people would have to take time
off for surgery and maybe like yeah good
for you man you get to live that was
funny like when we we went on tour with
Conan like after The Tonight Show and
like I got to play the master Brady
marriage is really fun but there's a
bunch of yeah yeah yeah but um but you
know everyone else was like a
professional except for like the five of
us who worked on the show we're like
professional tour a professional touring
company and they worked with like Weezer
and like our tour manager is like the
manager for the Foo Fighters and all
that stuff and so they lived their lives
on the road and it was really
interesting because that days off we had
they would be like okay I'm gonna go to
the dentist and do this and do this and
if you like oh right like that's the
only time yes Yeah right exactly exactly
which is like saying it's so weird
because I'm sure people are like oh my
gosh like all these people when they
have time off they probably the crazy
lives it's like no that's when we leave
our normal yes yeah there's a lot of
paying bills not sleeping right now and
the Wanderlust of it all to be in a
different place it's interesting like
cuz I think one of the things that kind
of struck me one of the things I learned
on tour and and I don't know how you
feel but it it was almost like I kind of
understood at a certain point why rock
bands like trash hotel rooms cuz like
okay right they lost their mind but it's
like you know you do get this sense of
when you're leaving the next day of like
there's very
little consequence because they're not
gonna be there and it's also like Oh No
Oh roach that was touch-and-go there for
a second that Griffin head was really
bringing us down yeah I love like we're
just like people on the road wasn't
knocking them with a giant bloody
Griffin head yeah
but also like going into we would
sometimes stay in these really nice
hotels and you just be so tired and it's
like all I want is an outlet to plug in
my phone and all these and like I
remember pulling like a giant chest of
drawers like away from the wall just to
find it out I'd be like why can't they
put an outlet on the web like a motel 6
really exactly yeah I know it's just it
just drives me nuts
uh have you played Assassin's Creed love
Fassbender didn't see it though I love
Michael Fassbender he is a favorite
actor of mine for sure classic ajaces
shadow viper snake perfect rockers love
to get drunk yeah I mean also the drugs
to is why they Keith Moon destroyed
hotel rooms not just because he needed
an outlet to plug in his phone and I'm
saying there's also that other that's
right chillin in vizima Chris is so cute
though so there's like two girls that
you can pick right one is like the
adorable sweet one who's got like these
cute freckles and she's got red hair hmm
and like in real life I'd probably date
her sure but uh Jennifer is like the
girl you don't bring home to mama yeah
so much I consider myself more of a
Jennifer you're not that I I think
you'll see me as a yennefer you know cuz
I'm a bad boy right back right I'm a bad
boy
yeah all I do is read and weep that's my
bubble profile says just like I read and
we need not read it and weep I read and
weep oh that's interesting yeah
as our Aussie asked you still watched
obw today I haven't but I have friends
that are there and so I keep promising
them a lot of matches right right yes um
but I always I compare it to like if you
like went through divorce oh well sure
yes you have to right you're tied to
them for life right for me there comes a
day I don't work at Conan which at this
point is seeming less and less that I'll
probably just die while working here I
would I will never watch the show I have
seen him like every day when I go on
vacation and I'm flipping around on the
TV and he pops up I'm like I don't see
I'm in like the Bahamas I get off my TV
I would never watch dub I mean not the
fact I loved WWE but I can see like
you've done it you're in it you know all
those people just please leave me alone
I've done it it's enough that's enough
do I did oh sure of course you know it's
hard to know how the sausage is made and
yes absolutely absolutely it is a
totally different thing and that's why
like I understand when like Johnny Depp
or somebody they say like oh I don't
watch my movies that I'm an why not it's
like will do because if you're watching
like Clarets the curbing he if he's
watching it he's not like wow this is
such a funny scene he's like oh my hat
was so itchy
all that eyeliner is in my eye was hot
that's it you know like it's a very
different experience yeah of course yeah
it was also hard for me to watch myself
just cuz I feel like oh god yeah why do
I make this I know right yes oh damn
just for you whoo actually people are
asking do you like horror games in the
chat I just finished a Resident Evil 7
which was awesome
whoa-ho oh my god that game is
horrifying Resident Evil games have been
I liked them when they were like sure
yes yes they totally are it's so great
it's very Texas Chainsaw Massacre
which is cool in a different direction
and there's moments where I was just
like nope no play alone yeah it was very
also it's also a VR it's the same game
every reality you you should just nice
try it it is so scary I work it just it
just goes right over your glasses yeah
it works out they figured that out for
us nerds that's right which game will
come to play the next clueless camera I
can't tell you we're shooting it on
Wednesday but my lips are sealed
maybe Bubble Bobble who knows I don't
know you know good bubble of good
bobbles were like it would be so
cautious
[Laughter]
exactly oh if you know when I'm on Starz
ass edgy if you had the opportunity to
portray Catwoman would you take the role
or not hey you love Catwoman take why
are they asking Catwoman do you love
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah they restart yeah it's
because like the alt like old Harlequin
old Catwoman by the way is I love the
Michelle Pfeiffer crazy like stitches oh
that's so great but yeah they were like
redoing it again I don't know I didn't
even read the other old 52 eye out for
that hole
it's too much I didn't even read Civil
War I was like my love for Harley
Quinn's
like yeah what's in the sure yes yes
exactly 999 feet tall yes right you know
funny should say that there's a bunch of
pictures in this book and one of them is
actually of an action figure it was
supposed that was supposed to be made
there you go
but there's let's go full screen on this
bad boy you're gonna want to see this
there it is right there
oh wait where's my finger there it is
there's you in the cane mask and then
right below is a Harley Quinn cane
mashup toy yes yes stand but like I did
love her in the animated series I was a
big fan it was so great yeah Oh mr. J
but yeah so yes she would play Catwoman
Tim Burton when you restart the Batman
franchise after we're done with the
whole Ben Affleck thing yes let's do it
you know it's kind of interesting though
like so now your books getting some
steam by the way the book crazy the
superpower out now it's on the New York
Times bestseller list I put it right in
front of your face that's a great way to
do it yeah well that's true that's right
yeah don't make me tell you my butt so
if they make a movie out of this
who do you think would play you would
you play you I don't think you could
play yourself that feels like a little
too I would get you you can play your
sister I kind of like that that's a fun
right yeah exactly
I love it that's the way to do it that's
the Hollywood take no that's the way to
do the look Seymour Hoffman is passed
away so he can't do it he's amazed
amazing actor I bet he could pull it off
I'm just say spoiler alert I'm sorry
okay yeah whatever span that's panic
thanks chef banks banks sure I'm
actually wearing a full-body Spanx thing
now thank you it's very realistic right
there
okay yeah I can see that sure yeah
your hair is similar I could see that
the hair she wouldn't have to wear a wig
or something Brock lesner I would like
to see Brock in a wig III know no one
that I like to sort of and you come out
it feels like how I imagined people who
just come out of prison or like what is
this cellphone yeah you're like a way at
summer camp
that's right exactly that's funny yeah I
don't know like
a bunch of women finally so wet anthe
goes I love girls with giant foreheads
you know I say that to girls at the bar
all the time and for some reason I end
up covered in their drink yeah more more
forehead to love Georgia I love we
should have just started the stream with
just asking you all the games you've
played have you played evil within
even with Venus yeah and it's like
you're going back and forth through a
mirror I think isn't that even within or
am i thinking of the wrong I know I
might be thinking okay I think you're
the one where you're cop and then you go
into the building everyone's been
murdered
oh yeah and then I think later you're
you go back and forth between a
different dimension know exactly who is
more intimidating sitting next to Page
or AJ they're both intimidating they're
women and I'm intimidated by that every
page was here before yeah she liked
bodyslam me or something it's like I get
it everyone's stronger yes Paige is
great too
David Marcus I'm only 500 pounds be
beefed up dude get on a bullet if you're
only 500 you can go bigger actually you
know it's gotta be fun is like now you
can kind of eat whatever you want
oh yeah right off the training regimen
yeah I retired I came home to be very
fit yes I can imagine
oh my god I'm wearing camo right now to
try to blame yeah yes can't see them so
the first thing I did is I went to
Target what were some of these send me
toast crunch you do that got to do your
Captain Crunch right Oh Reese's puffs
what oh my god we've flown too close to
the Sun
I know we put a man on the moon but like
a Thin Mint cereal is kind of more
impressive I'm not gonna lie yeah that's
unbelievable 1,500 happy points but
that's not a thing I'm trying to related
to two Witcher it's not skinny doesn't
feel I agree with that 100% I would I'm
not a donuts guy though so I would say
crunchy Cheetos I'm more of a salty
that's not my that's my terrible yes I'm
more of a salt like sweet stuff is like
a bits oh my god
I literally I had a loss about I lost
like 90 pounds lost a bunch of weight so
I didn't eat anything like and then I
had like a cheat day where I ate like I
had the five things I wanted not a lot
of it but like I had pancakes bread
crunchy Cheetos Pizza Pizza was the last
thing and you know what oh and Taco Bell
by the way had more and a brunch it was
like I had all my friends come but the
one thing was like crunchy Cheetos I was
like take this away it's like crack
cocaine it's like I would it's less it's
it's more addictive than correct to me
it's crazy definitely when you are yes
so he says oh how did I like I like less
vascular and happier right you D hi did
you drink like water it's like it
doesn't it doesn't work like that
that's hilarious well level is displayed
on goddammit candy be the easiest level
because over the weekend I just tried to
get as far as possible and and by the
way we didn't get we were we ended up
like looking for buckthorn was how we
first started if you're just joining us
we're with AJ Mendes Brooks and by the
way if you're in
not gonna put it over your face if
you're in Los Angeles on Wednesday age
you will be at meltdown comics over on
the Westside at 6 p.m. doing a signing
of this fantastic book
a story of her life that's on the New
York Times bestseller list soon to be a
movie starring brockless orchards I'm
just starting that what's your Uncharted
game stance okay
yes right perimeter says I'm indecisive
oh I'd be mad street cred if you named
my cat what's a good name for a cat uh
human name Yeah right begin you know you
went you went Larry Talbot I like the
name Franklin that's good
what about just like Franklin Roosevelt
Franklin yeah exactly Franklin there we
go we did it we did it together
team we did Julian says listen to this
while playing GTA 5 and this is
undeniably better dude I was on the
radio in place city yeah I was I said
something about like my wife cheating on
me I said something so there's like a
ghost and yeah yeah the only time
anyone's ever been impressed only time
ever and then I was also in San Andreas
as like a 25% of all the personal
trainers and joggers yes if you if you
kill four joggers one of them will be me
because when I told
trying here a lot but like right off
that game came out and all my friends
knew I just started getting pictures of
like dead characters does people be like
I killed you just like horribly maimed
yeah that's great I have terrible
friends yeah you have to fun one of the
first ones that came out there was like
submission we have to bring a bunch of
hookers to like a police ball something
like that or for me a Tuesday right and
so I was just like stopping and like
honking at any hooker and I was like
wait which which things should we pick
here we want to dress up I think they're
all kind of
oh yeah no the only the middle one looks
different right different all the scars
oh boy that's why I wax my back you know
just show off your scars Yeah right to
show up yes the shaman take all please
and I'm sure now we have to go into some
submenu please don't make me go into it
men you put your clothes on yeah this is
a good look there's a term for it and I
keep trying to remember it shirt cuffing
yeah maybe I don't know internet should
be able to internet television he looks
like a guy by the way who like puts his
like towel like doesn't like to be seen
Nate puts his towel on because he was
like wearing his towel just gonna go
nude man right in a towel there's like a
way to do it
nothing is seen but you you manipulate
the towel see I would just go Batman
smoke bomb just boom sudden
Batman smoke bombs my life yeah exactly
everyone's like it would be amazing what
a great way to end a conversation so
easy it'll be way way less on every
breakup ever in my life please if only
you could do a smoke bomb on a text just
like or whatever just terrible oh wait
so what do you like what what are some
of the emoji I should know how to tell
you how to get this I think if you could
be okay and is it you are they yeah it's
like it's like little stickers I guess
they call them I don't know I'm a
grandma um so I'd like just texting
everyone my phone book just like
nonsensical that's so cool dude that's
great are there other checks in there no
but there's donuts and a joystick
perfect that's awesome how do we we need
this is the worst thing I've ever done
in my life
just what are we letting leg extended
hand flat but this is head down in the
chest so what is it what did he do we
weren't he he went like this which means
he put his right hand on chest there we
go this is it right oh my god oh wait
what rock bands do you like I
interrupted you with the thank you by
the way for reminding us I appreciate
that I think one of my favorite bands of
all time is metric
I just like kind of relate to like
lyrics yeah more than anything
taco cats yes what wait what does
tacocat sideways okay so they have this
song I can't wait to hear this is good
Dana Katherine Scully okay love it
already x-files for though so I'm
listening to them right now yeah I guess
I'd be okay new found another friend
Anthony all just showed up online and I
love it that's gotta support your
friends man
points also Beth put the link to AJ's
emojis oh this is a great question as he
says hey I was wondering do you play
xbox or playstation in the book on about
the apogee that says playstation however
the cupboard says Xbox oh my god
you can just sit people are married are
angry that you're married no one cares
that I'm married
yeah that's just as well how are you
nice to see you
am I too close this is creepy no this is
nice this is my hand is just the man
that's what you want say hi to the chat
hi YouTube and hey YouTube and twitch
that's really got our twitch we got
YouTube why is it why aren't people
working what are they doing I don't know
why are my eyes everybody work is what's
the gross national product is falling
the production in America is down what
are you playing what's your like what's
your I do I actually beat it he's a
little too
I tried because I explain it's not angry
not it just you know I I'm not angry
no no just very reverence I'm more
reverent and unhappy I'm happier I was
just saying we we when we played the
game company helped us out so he asked
us where we wanted yeah I all I wanted
to do would have sat on the uniform and
they'd let us
they got us to that point because I was
not going to get there on my own
simulated my my youth there's not going
to is no one's gonna happen unless I had
a lot of help right so that was
fantastic it was very erotic but now I
had I played over the weekend I didn't
get very far say Jays making funny just
beat this game I did play a lot it you
play constantly yes
that's all that's how it's been my mic-n
do you think would you like to see Conan
play what game you've played a lot of
great games what do you think we should
do for a clueless gamer in the yeah
what's the next game play oh I don't
know something new no yeah well doesn't
have to be but usually it helps when
it's a new game yeah we have anima
Gregory dudes on the car MacGregor yeah
play with him okay and I swear to God in
person I think it's gonna sound crazy
but when you're in the same space as
Conor McGregor you see that I'm a large
man right I look at him and I think I
could rip your head off
I really do small he's much smaller than
me and I and he's much lighter than me
and I just keep thinking I want to go
for it I think I could take him which
would be a mistake I think we're agreed
that's sure that I couldn't for a second
take the trigger but there's an optical
illusion when I'm around him that I
could beat him that's true beat him to
Daddy take his shoe off and hit him with
it and then he when he was on the show
he did that thing where he you asked him
to do a crazy kick and he came within
like cuz he has such control within
inches a crazy like yeah then he was
annoyed cuz I didn't pull my head back
right I actually leaned in a little bit
the lawsuit so what's your style of
fighting like right now if I was coming
at you and I was how do you defend
yourself that's nice
so that's your style if a man is coming
at you while you're seated on the same
cab Bank and now that now that she's
retired from WWE just recently by the
way this is me you're so young you're
like I guess it's my god yes I
understand that's a sexy cover you have
yeah this is a book that I'm not allowed
to read reading
look look at that that's so it's it's a
great shot thank you yeah we were
celebrating the fact she no longer has
to have apps you no longer has to work
out so hard right you know but just like
see yeah seems like a good thing like
you know what I'm saying like right
I don't know right you've been lifting
weights I take care of myself
come on just grab that that's not bad
right whoa right there hard to get the
ABS if you were Irish Irish don't have I
don't even think I'd be hard to get a
six-pack - I agree our skin is like a
sort of salmon it's gone bad look good
no one ever wants me to take my shirt
off I think even Connor doesn't have
again another reason why I could I'm not
going to travel it's gonna be when he
doesn't know it charity benefit with him
we'll be chatting and then I will just
Co Denmark says hi also so Denmark 101st
airborne said hi 101st airborne I salute
you that's right yeah we were to go to
Qatar with the first lady yes that's
right that's right and we were the Qatar
Air Force Base I think that's the
largest base maybe want to largest bases
in the world yes that's true certainly
in the Middle East that's a great face I
think I hung out there I stayed I lived
on the base that's fun in the barracks
fantastic it's a great experience blue
great men and women they're also AJ and
I were talking about cuz she's basically
spent a lot of her life on the road we
went on tour he was crate you wrote on
the bus and everything that was fun for
a section that you are you were talking
about do you know do you think to keep
my carbon footprint low that's not true
I didn't care
I desperately wanted a plane the
gasoline but that's a lot of money what
did you think of the tour life would you
go back on to her yeah I'd love to do
that yeah I love the tour life the
problem is that you're doing the show
every day yes so that's what gets in the
way of I need to get fired and I'm
working on this I'm sorry my leg is
touching your knee is that a problem
I'm very chilly she's married by the way
I know just to see him yeah I know
so now how fast would a fight between me
and your husband last he's an amazing
athlete right how did you know he was
the right one when you met him um well
after our first kiss I threw him through
a table
ten feet for the air is that true yes
[Laughter]
that was a mating ritual by the way
everyone in the chat is just saying hey
true story I played paintball this
weekend I'd like someone to play
paintball so my son and his friends oh I
play paintball
and this guy's jumped out from behind a
structure you're not supposed to shoot
when you're that close yeah this guy was
about three inches from me and pumped
three rounds oh my god into my oh look
at that and yeah and gave me this baby
right here and it really hurt really
hurt you're not supposed to do it that
close and then I saw the same guy do it
to a little kid like ten minutes later
there's a guy out there in Bellflower
California yeah he just brings his own
aquit he's not even playing he's a
sociopath he's not even sure that was a
painful
I don't know that what that was that was
quite painful that's insane yeah oh my
god well I think guys I'm sorry to say I
think we're out of time hey someone said
my biceps look like potato dumpling I
can see what you're writing you're right
yes yeah three dumplings dumplings in a
row what's happening why are you leaving
me we're out of time we're out of time
hey Internet look where I am you can
dream about where I am but I'm living in
thank you to Anja Mendez Brooks the book
is crazy as my superpower it's out now
and I and and conor mcgregor at the same
time twitter agent brewing on an
official agent Mendez on Instagram
thinking when you're just yelling he's
just Yeller
we'll see you guys next week thank you
see you later bye
you
you